for this week's classic interview we're
going to revisit my discussion with
Claire Conner who talked to us about how
individuals can and often do escape
their families extremism and this is a
particularly relevant concept right now
with the coalescing catalyzing and
fomenting of really horrible extremism
record number of hate incidents under
President Donald Trump and this
discussion over how much is Trump
directly fomenting that and how much is
happening by virtue of the sort of cult
of personality that his supporters have
created around him the discussion with
Claire O'Connor never more relevant at
least during the time of the David
Pakman show exists instead it is today
we will go to my interview with her from
nearly six years ago and think about it
as I reviewed it over the weekend
thinking about it in the context of the
Trump presidency and the coalescing and
fomenting of extremism that we've been
tracking now for more than two years
today Claire Conner is with us her new
book wrapped in the flag is her story of
being raised by extremist parents in a
household that embraced the John Birch
Society and the radical right she was
able to escape and lead her life as a
progressive Claire it's so great to talk
to you and I'm on this program we do a
lot with extremism and many times we
talk to extremists just last week we had
a a white separatist self-described and
talked with him about his goals and his
ideas and kind of where his beliefs came
from you have a very different situation
which is that your parents were two of
the first Chicago members of the John
Birch Society and you were in a
situation where the upbringing clearly
should have led you maybe to be a right
winger but that's not how it ended up so
let's start first with kind of your
upbringing and what that was like well
first of all thank you very much for
having you David I'm really excited to
have this opportunity to talk to you and
hear your audience first thing I think
people need to understand is the John
Birch Society in the 1960s was the best
funded most successful and most powerful
right-wing populists
organization that the United States had
ever seen
we did populist right-wing movements
before but in this particular case the
founder of the John Birch Society a
fella named Robert Welsh actually
figured out how to get all of the
membership working on the same thing at
the same time and he used a very
monolithic approach so what he said is
what the John Birch Society did this is
not an organization that embraced the
concept of democracy farther within
itself or for the country at large my
father was the first member of the John
Birch Society in the city of Chicago and
my mother was the second they believed
so much in the cause then in 1959 they
wrote a check to the John Birch Society
for $2,000 for to live memberships that
would be like you David writing a check
for $12,500 today for membership they
were true believers my father became a
member of the National Council in 1960
when just after the National Council
which is an advisory group to Robert
Welsh just after it was founded so
interestingly enough he remained on the
leadership for 32 years this is not a
man who changed his views backtracked or
rethought his positions he remained a
true believer all of his life and even
after I left the Birch Society
he was constantly recruiting me back
into the cause so as you were growing up
I mean what at what point did you you
know for a certain time kids kind of
don't know that there are really other
options right it's just what your
parents tell you that's the status quo
it's your frame of reference period what
was the catalyst that made you start to
kind of re-evaluate where you were
politically well I think people think
this moment when I left out you know
left up and said I'm not doing this
anymore actually the story is much more
complex than that and I think it's an
object lesson for anybody who thinks
about how people live in extremism it
takes a long time it's I tell audiences
it was like one step forward to back a
half a step forward I wanted very much
to please my parents I loved my father I
loved my mother and there were very
powerful strong and compelling people so
it took probably 25 years of reading and
struggle before I was finally able to
say this is not my vision for America I
don't believe in what the John Birch
Society is preaching now the first step
forward for me had to do with meeting a
fella named Ruffalo Oliver when I was 14
years old
Rebelo Oliver was one of the John Birch
Society leaders like my dad and once my
father became a leader a whole parade of
Bergers went in and out of our life our
home in Chicago was like the stopping
point for birched leadership rebel of
Oliver's to come over quite often and he
was a fellow who was very educated a
classics professor and he had a profound
impact on my parents because Rebelo
Oliver did not believe that there was a
Holocaust during the World War two huh
so suddenly even though I'd been raised
in a Jewish neighborhood and had learned
about the Holocaust when I was a little
girl
even before the word Holocaust was
applied to the wars in Germany suddenly
my father was saying well you know the
Germans were really just trying to stop
the Communists from taking over in
Germany I thought my father and last is
night was positive rebel of Oliver and
helped him now that may not sound a
particular significance to people until
you think about this dr. rivela honor if
you google him today
you'll find out the Revel Oh Oliver is
the father of the neo-nazi movement
right it would talk to that white
supremacist last week that you were
sharing about David he would have been
very knowledgeable about rebel Oh Oliver
rebel Oh Oliver has coined the term
hallo hoax and that term is used all
across the anti-semitic of far-right
today in addition rebel Oh Oliver talked
to app to Andrew Pierce who was
originally a bird Sir Andrew Pierce
talk to me to writing a novel about the
white supremists takeover of America
that novel is called the Turner Diaries
now interesting about the Turner Diaries
when the police stopped Timothy McVeigh
about an hour after the Oklahoma City
bombing what did they find in his car
but excerpts from the Turner Diaries
incredible incredible you know we we
only have a few minutes left and there's
a lot of other things I wanted to touch
base with you on so a few things I
wanted to ask about one was before your
parents passed away ultimately what was
your relationship like with them or how
did it change as a result of your
changed political views it was a very
very contentious relationship I lived in
the same time with my parents so I had a
lot of responsibility and concern toward
the end of their lives and did
everything I could to help them but they
were very very angry I think one of the
keys to understanding the far right is
they are angry they are angry they are
angry at the government and they're
angry at people who don't agree with
them so my mother used to say you are a
disgrace to the country and to our
family but the most important thing that
I want to share with people is I learned
something from living in the radical
right
I learned that extremism breaks families
it breaks families apart
it destroys relationships it is full of
a sort of paranoia and hate that's
really bad for families but more
important than that
I don't want extremism to break my
country so that's why I wrote my book
to share the story of what it's like
growing up in extremism how I escaped
and why it matters to the United States
today so how did you now now
with your children taking in what you
learned and what you've experienced with
the dynamic with your parents how how is
the conversation about politics
happening around your children because
the case could be made that maybe they
on their own might choose right-wing
beliefs and it could be just as wrong
for you to push progressive beliefs on
to them I think that there would be
diverging views about that but how have
you handled politics with your children
well I was
pretty much policy wonk David because I
was raised in a political family I find
politics very interesting and for a very
long time my kids thought I was a
Republican interesting honey so it was
what I wanted my children to understand
is there's a difference between
conservatives and extremists there's a
big difference and extremist
philosophies are dangerous to the
governance of the United States I think
we actually need a viable second party
we need a GOP we do you can't have a
one-party system that works at all well
with our constitutional structures but
the point is that what's happened in the
Republican Party today is that this
radical right has taken it over
so you see John Boehner you hear policy
ideas prescribed by the leadership of
the GOP which sound exactly like when I
what was prescribed by the John Birch
Society
way back when so it's a repetition of
the same sort of we hate the government
we want to hobble the government we want
to dismantle the government long before
Grover Norquist got the idea of drowning
the government in the bathtub the John
Birch Society believed in that so I
think there's a big difference at the
same time I also think that we have to
be clear as progressives that we need to
talk about how governance works and what
America should look like I do not
believe it should look like anything
imagined by the John Birch Society we've
been speaking with Claire Conner the new
book is wrapped in the flag make sure to
take a look at that book excellent read
Claire thank you so much for being on
with us today and we will be back with
plenty more right after this